foreign
[Music]
Member of Parliament for Braintree his
Majesty's Secretary of State for foreign
Commonwealth and development Affairs so
thank you
my Lord mayor
your excellencies Mr Speaker my Lord's
ladies and gentlemen
thank you for inviting me to speak with
you this evening and whilst it is
traditional
in this speech to cover the full breadth
of world affairs you will I hope forgive
me for focusing on a smaller number of
issues which confront us because it
would be remiss of me not to begin with
the current crisis in Sudan
as you would expect I've been in Cobra
meetings and other meetings on our
response to this situation today
I can inform you that a royal Air Force
flight has now left Sudan carrying
British Nationals to safety this evening
and more will follow
from the onset of this crisis we've been
planning how to get our people out
and now that our and international calls
for ceasefire in Khartoum have been
heeded we are putting those plans into
effect giving priority to those in
greatest need family groups the sick and
the elderly
I'm encouraged that both factions have
called a 72-hour ceasefire that of
course we cannot be sure for how long it
will hold and any evacuation from a
battle scarred city is inherently
dangerous
Britain is working hand in glove with
our partners across the world and after
this operation we will do everything
possible alongside our friends in the
region to secure a lasting settlement
for this tragic conflict
and of course the situation in Sudan
does not distract us from our work to
support Ukraine's struggle against
Russian aggression
and I know that my G7 colleagues and
other colleagues around the world will
agree on our focus on that
even when the
are seemingly all-consuming it is vital
that we never lose sight of the biggest
long-term questions
so tonight I propose to focus on a
subject that will Define our epoch
and that is China
and the UK's policy towards it
I'm often asked to express that policy
in a single phrase or sum up China
itself in one word whether threat or
partner or adversary
and I want to start by explaining why
that is impossible
impractical
and most importantly
unwise
China is one of the few countries which
can trace its existence back over two
Millennia to two two one BC when it was
United by the Qin dynasty
time and time again down the centuries
Civil War or foreign invasions fractured
China into rival kingdoms but after
every period of turmoil China has always
re-emerged
the opening line of the Chinese epic
Romance of the Three Kingdoms describes
this cycle
Empires wax and Wayne States cleave
asunder
and coalesce
and long before they coalesced into one
polity the Chinese people created their
language and their civilization their
written characters appeared in the Shang
Dynasty in the second millennium BC
their inventions paper
printing Gunpowder the compass these
things transformed The Fortunes of the
whole of humanity
and these Innovations are key to
understanding why China's economy was
among the biggest in the world for 20 of
the last 22 centuries
and why China in 1820
comprised a third of global GDP more
than America the UK and Europe combined
then Calamity struck
one after another
some caused by Foreign aggression others
coming from within China itself the
deadliest of which
was Mao's famine
which claimed tens of millions of lives
more than any other famine
in human history
yet
the last 45 years have seen another
astonishing reversal
by releasing the enterprising Genius of
its people
China has achieved the biggest and
fastest economic expansion the world has
ever known
no less than 800 million people have
lifted themselves out of poverty in a
nation that encompasses a fifth of all
Humanity
and a vast area almost as large as
Continental Europe from the Atlantic
to the Euros
say
forgive me when I say that no Punchy
catchphrase or plausible adjective can
do justice to such a country or to any
sensible approach towards it
if you are looking for British foreign
policy by sound bite
I'm afraid you will be disappointed
my starting point
is a recognition of the depth and
complexity of Chinese history and
civilization and therefore by extension
of our own policy
and I rest that policy on a series of
premises
the first of which
is that whatever our differences with
China's leaders
I rejoice in the fact that so many
Chinese people have escaped poverty
we do not live in a miserable zero-sum
world
their gain is our game
a stable
prosperous and peaceful China is good
for Britain
and good for the world
looking ahead
I reject any notion of inevitability
no one predicted China's rapid rise from
Mass starvation to relevant relative
prosperity
and today
no one can be sure that China's economic
Juggernaut will roll on indefinitely
last year
for the first time since Mao's death in
China's economy grew no faster
than the world economy
meaning that China's share of global GDP
stayed constant in 2022
and even if China does become the
world's largest economy in the coming
decade
it may not hold that place for long
as a declining and aging population
weighs ever more heavily on future
growth
nor do I see anything inevitable about
conflict between China and the United
States and the wider West we are not
compelled to be the prisoners of what
Graham Allison called The thucydides
Trap
whereby a rising power follows the
trajectory of ancient Athens and
collides head-on with an established
superpower
we have agency
we have choices
and so do our Chinese counterparts
our task
shape the course of future events not to
succumb to fatalism
and we must face the inescapable reality
that no significant Global problem
from climate change to pandemic
prevention from economic instability to
nuclear proliferation can be solved
without China
to give up on dialogue with China would
be to give up on addressing Humanity's
greatest problems
even worse
we would be ignoring Salient facts vital
to our safety and to our prosperity
as I speak
the biggest repository of Health Data in
the world
is in China
the biggest source of active ingredients
for the world's Pharmaceuticals
is in China
and the biggest source of carbon
emissions
is also in China
indeed China has pumped more carbon into
the atmosphere in the last 10 years
than this country has since the dawn of
the Industrial Revolution in the 18th
century
how China regulates its data how China
develops its Pharmaceuticals how China
conducts medical research will be of
seminal importance
to the whole of humanity
and whether or not China Cuts its carbon
emissions will probably make the
difference between our planet avoiding
the worst ravages of climate change
or suffering catastrophes
we've already learned to our cost how
China's handling of a pandemic
can affect the entire world
so have no doubt decisions taken in
Beijing are going to affect our lives
do we not owe it to ourselves to strive
to influence those decisions in our own
interests
it would be clear
and easy
and perhaps even satisfying for me to
declare some kind of new Cold War and
say that our goal is to isolate China
it would be clear
it would be easy it will be satisfying
and it would be wrong
because it would be a betrayal of our
national interest and a willful
misunderstanding of the modern world
indeed this government will advance
British interests directly with China
alongside our allies while steadfastly
defending our national security
and our values
and we can expect profound disagreements
dealing with China I can assure you is
not a job for the faint-hearted
they represent a ruthless authoritarian
tradition utterly at odds with our own
but
we have an obligation to Future
generations to engage because otherwise
we would be failing in our duty to
sustain and shape the international
order
shirking that challenge would be a sign
not of strength
but of weakness
Vladimir Putin never intended to
demonstrate the power of a United West
when he launched his Onslaught against
Ukraine
but our response shows that when Britain
in America and Europe and our other
partners across the world
Stand United
we are indeed a match
for anything
and so we should have every confidence
in our Collective ability to engage
robustly
and also constructively with China
not as an end in itself
but to manage risks
and to produce results
and we have achieved results
let me give you some examples in 2017
research
British research
convinced Chinese agricultural Ministry
to act against the danger of antibiotic
resistance by restricting colistin an
antibiotic used in animal feed
sales fell by 90 percent
making everyone in the world safer
last year
our diplomats in China helped to
persuade the authorities to amend a
draft procurement law improving the
chances of UK companies bidding for
contracts from state-owned Enterprises
this year they secured licenses worth
600 million pounds for UK institutions
to launch fund management companies in
China
Britain's position
as a founding member of the Asia
infrastructure Investment Bank has also
allowed us to influence China's approach
towards this new Institution
preventing it from becoming a
politicized extension of the belt and
Road initiative
China is the biggest shareholder of this
Bank
the bank is headquartered in Beijing and
yet within a week of Russia's full-scale
brutal invasion of Ukraine it it froze
every single project in Russia
but
even though engagement can succeed
the truth is
a country like ours devoted to Liberty
and democracy will always be torn
between our national interest in dealing
with China
and our abhorrence
of beijing's abuses
when we see how authoritarian States
treat their own people
we wonder what they would do to us
if they had the chance
and history teaches us that repression
at home
often translates into aggression abroad
so our policy has to combine two
currents we must engage with China where
necessary and be unflinchingly realistic
about its authoritarianism
and that means never wavering from one
clear principle
we do not expect our disagreements with
China to be swiftly overcome
but we do expect China to observe the
laws and obligations that it has freely
entered into
so
as a permanent member of the United
Nations security Council
China shouldered a special
responsibility to uphold the UN Charter
as a party to the Joint declaration
China has agreed to preserve Hong Kong's
freedom
as a signatory to the universal
Declaration of Human Rights
to the convention Against torture and
many other instruments of international
law China has accepted an array of
obligations and if China breaks them
we are entitled to say so and we are
entitled to act
and we will
as we did when China dismantled the
freedoms of Hong Kong violating its own
pledges
which is why we gave nearly 3 million of
Hong Kong's people a path to British
citizenship
peaceful coexistence has to begin with
respecting fundamental laws and
institutions including the UN Charter
which protects every country against
Invasion and that means every country
a Chinese Diplomat in Paris cannot and
must not and will not decide the legal
status of a Sovereign Nation
by attacking Ukraine Russia has provided
an object lesson in how a UN member
State should not behave
and Putin is also trampled upon China's
own stated principle of non-interference
and respect for sovereignty
a powerful and responsible Nation
cannot simply abstain when this happens
or draw closer to the aggressor or Aid
and a bet that aggression
a country that wants to be a country
that wants a respected place at the apex
of the world order
should stand up for its own principles
and keep in solemn obligations
obligations to defend the laws at the
very Foundation of that order
this responsibility goes hand in hand
with China's right
to play a global role commensurate with
its size and its history
and the rights of a Sovereign Nation
like Ukraine
cannot be eradicated just because the
The Eradicator enjoys a strategic
partnership
with China
so
British policy towards China has three
pillars first
we will strengthen our national security
protections
wherever beijing's actions pose a threat
to our people
or our prosperity we are not going to be
silent about interference in our
political system
or technology theft
or industrial sabotage we will do more
to safeguard academic freedom and
research
and when there are tensions with other
objectives
we will always put our National Security
First and we are building our 5G Network
in the most secure way
not the fastest or the cheapest way
China's leaders Define their core
interests and its natural that they do
but we have core interests too and one
of them is to promote the kind of world
that we want to live in where people
everywhere
have a universal human right to be
treated with dignity
free from torture
free from slavery
free from arbitrary detention and there
is nothing uniquely Western about these
values
torture hurts just as much whoever it is
inflicted upon
so when Britain condemns the mass incar
the mass incarceration of the uyghur
people in Muslim it sorry the uyghur
people in xinjiang
I hope our Chinese counterparts do not
believe their own rhetoric that we are
merely seeking to interfere in their
domestic affairs
just as we should try harder to
understand China
I hope that Chinese officials will
understand
that when their government builds a 21st
century version of the gulag archipelago
locking up over a million people at the
height of this campaign
often for doing nothing more than
observing their religion
this stirs something deep within us
when the United Nations finds that
China's repression in xinjiang May and I
quote constitute International crimes in
particular
crimes against humanity
our revulsion is heartfelt and shared
unanimously across our country
and Beyond we are not going to let what
is happening in xinjiang drop
or be brushed aside we cannot ignore
this simply because it is happening on
the other side of a frontier or that to
raise it might be considered
unharmonious or impolite
second
the UK will deepen our cooperation and
strengthen our alignment with friends
and partners in the indo-pacific and
across the world
our aim will be to bolster collective
security
deepen commercial links uphold
international law
and balance and compete where necessary
so I'm delighted
that Britain will soon be the 12th
member of the trans-pacific partnership
reinforcing our trading ties with
rapidly growing economies
already we are the only European country
to be a dialogue partner of the
association of South East Asian Nations
and we are deepening our long-term
partnership with India and we are
developing the next generation of combat
aircraft alongside Japan and we've
joined the United States to help
Australia to build nuclear-powered
conventionally armed submarines under
the orcas partnership
together with our friends the UK will
strive for openness and transparency in
the indo-pacific
this moment
China is carrying out the biggest
military buildup in peacetime history
in a period of just four years between
2014 and 2018
China launched new warships
exceeding the combined tonnage
of the Royal Navy's entire active Fleet
and as we see this happening as we watch
new bases appear in the South China Sea
and Beyond
we are bound to ask ourselves what is it
all for
why is China making this colossal
military investment
and if we are left to draw our own
conclusions Prudence dictates that we
must assume the worst
and yet of course you could be wrong
it is possible that we will we will be
too cautious
two pessimistic
and the UK and our allies are prepared
to be open about our presence
in the indo-pacific
and I urge China to be equally open
about the doctrine and intent behind its
military expansion because transparency
is surely in everyone's interest
and secrecy can only increase the risk
of tragic miscalculation
which brings me to Taiwan
Britain's long-standing position is that
we want to see a peaceful settlement of
the differences across the state across
the straight
because about half of the world's
container ships pass through these vital
Waters every year Laden with Goods Bound
for Europe and the Far Corners of the
world
Taiwan is a thriving democracy and a
crucial Link in Global Supply chains
particularly for advanced semiconductors
a war across the street would not only
be a human tragedy
it would destroy World Trade worth
2.6 trillion dollars
according to the Nikkei Asia
no country could Shield itself from the
repercussions distance would offer no
protection from this catastrophic blow
to the global economy
and indeed China most of all and I
shudder to contemplate the human and
financial ruin that would follow
so it is essential that no party
takes unilateral action to change the
status quo
and the third pillar of our policy
is to engage directly with China
bilaterally and multilaterally to
preserve and to create open
constructive
and stable relations reflecting China's
Global importance
we believe in a positive trade and
investment relationship whilst avoiding
dependencies in critical Supply chains
we want British companies to do business
with China just as American asean
Australian and EU companies currently do
and we will support their effort to make
the terms work for both sides pushing
for a Level Playing Field and fairer
competition
we have an interest
in continuing to benefit from Chinese
investment
but we don't want the long arm of the
Chinese Communist Party reaching towards
the central nervous system of our
country
and in the past we haven't always struck
the perfect balance between openness and
security but now we are gaining the
right legal powers to safeguard what we
must and be open where we can
above all
we need to be properly skilled for the
challenge
so we are doubling our funding for China
capabilities across government we've
allocated resources to build a new
British Embassy in Beijing and I'm
determined to reach agreement with
China's government so this Canberra seed
so our approach to China
must combine all of these currents
protecting our national security
aligning with our friends
engaging and trading with China where
our interests converge
avoiding policy by sound bite and always
standing up for the universal values
which Britain holds dear
I
fervently believe
there are no inevitabilities
the future
is ours to shape
in the humble knowledge
that how we respond to this challenge
now
will help Define
the modern world
thank you
[Applause]